yo it's your girlfriend need a rapper
and check me out on a bootleg cab
podcast let's get it
the bootleg cab podcast special guest in
here if any of the rapper is here
welcome yo welcome welcome
um you've had a quite a uh amazing four
weeks or so is that safe to say uh-huh a
month ago do you remember like where you
were follower wise because I think I
feel like I followed you when you're
around like 40 000 and that was maybe
like two weeks ago man yeah
like a month ago I say
I was at
well what I saw was like
16k
that's what I remember seeing it's a big
month you've been like a hundred and
fifteen thousand yeah yeah yeah yeah
I definitely seen like the last thing I
saw was probably I wasn't paying
attention like that but I definitely saw
16 yeah I think do you like when you
when you get a big influx in followers
like that
how much of like do you see the famous
blue checks following you like any of
the famous people who you like maybe
grew up watching or checking out like
you're like oh [__] so-and-so's
following me yeah for sure who was like
like two or three of those names where
you were like oh [__]
um well everybody we all just not coming
up but a couple of people that I've seen
that I was like oh [__]
um I say
glorilla glorilla yeah she's great
um
sexy red
um [__]
Fredo bang it was a couple of
[__] I was just like oh [__]
right
yeah
if you tap in with sexy where to go
around about working uh working out some
music
yeah I definitely did age and down
glow
I mean yeah
sexy sexy red is on fire right she's
cool as hell too like if you ever meet
her she's she's like uh I always say
like when you meet Boosie like he
doesn't disappoint yeah because you know
you'll meet like certain famous people
and you have this like idea who they are
and then you meet him and you're like uh
like when you meet boozy he's exactly
who you think he is yeah yeah when you
meet sexy red she's amazing for sure
she's incredible shout out to her
um how long have you been making music
since like um 2019 I've been taking this
years I just been to welcome to rap
though
so what made you like because it's a big
step to break out of your shell and out
of your comfort zone and become
vulnerable in front of a microphone
microphone and I like yeah like 2012
when I was doing it I was just doing
something no trying things with my
friends and then but I knew I had boss
because I thought I tried it I'm like
I'll eat this [__] hard
but then [__]
um time went by I was just I kept doing
it I just didn't take it serious until
2019. what was the difference for you to
start taking this serious
um I had a friend a best friend she
actually inspired me to do this to rap
um she used to be rapping she was real
popular more popular than me and I never
even like took it serious but she always
took it serious she was just like bro
you the rapper I'm I'm just popular or
whatever the case may be but she ended
up passing away in like 2017 and then
I agreed for like two years 2019 came I
got an action [__] for her damn so she's
like the whole inspiration to why you're
doing this [__] literally sure what's
your name Sanka rest in peace yeah rest
in peace do you have any unreleased
songs with her that you're holding on to
like no no no no I don't got no
unreleased she got some unreleased
though I'm like [__] I buy hop on that
yeah I gotta find it though I got like
yeah you got to get the file or
something get it on your album yeah for
sure that'd be crazy you grew up in
Chicago yeah South Side uh
I'm like when I think of like female
rappers from Chicago the name that
really comes to mind is Shauna who's
like obviously Sean is a legend oh yeah
you know she's like I don't remember
Shawna she was signed a dtp for a little
bit oh I I heard of it remember getting
some head get getting some head oh yeah
yeah I was getting some
oh well how long
yeah oh yeah yeah
from Chicago she is yeah
damn
who are you growing up listening to in
Chicago
see y'all my goodies not my goodies
Sierra oh Sierra was great yeah Sierra
um
little Mama my lip gloss is pop that's a
little mama getting some flowers today
feel me little mama for real
um I'm talking about real take it real
back
back back
definitely Chris Brown
love Mama
um
T-Pain you know a little [__] like that
I could go back but yeah there's some
they hard though that sounds like what
like a 106 and Park episode from when I
was like you feel me for sure who's the
best 106 and Park host is it the OG's is
it free in AJ
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah it's it's the
OG's yeah it's free and AJ it's free and
AJ for sure
damn I wish we could have one of them
again
yeah I'm surprised they haven't tried to
I want it to look just like that and I
want them to look just like how they
looked when I was I don't know if that's
gonna happen I know right that's what
I'm saying I think AJ's on Entertainment
Tonight
oh okay I free was doing morning radio
in DC I don't know what happened to free
shout out to her she's a legend but now
that Tyler Perry owns BT
hey maybe he might
bring it back write the check get free
and AJ back together that'd be an
interesting idea Tyler Perry it's not a
crazy idea you know it feels like an
obvious idea yeah that's if
for sure
um okay so you're obviously doing your
thing you have this record what
transpires to get cardi B well you want
her radar and obviously the song because
that obviously is a life-changing moment
a career changing moment
um
so
when
um
when cardi B manager reached out to me
to hop on the record
I'm like what the [__] I thought it was
a joke I didn't even think it was
serious because you know Carly she real
big like one of the biggest biggest you
know female I'm like the biggest artist
period period [__] female male period
you feel me so I I just really thought
that was like
Next Level uh another level and a whole
nother level type of thing like oh she
heard my lyrics She wanna get on the
song she heard the song
it was um literally a life changing but
when they reached out to me I'm like man
get back to them ASAP I told my manager
reached back out to them ASAP and um she
did exactly that and
we got on the phone me and cardi we end
up getting on the phone and we was
discussing it she loved the song she was
like I love this she was so sweet and
nice about it all and um I'm like you
know I do it in LA do the video in LA
she like
no
we coming to Chicago we going to Chicago
so that was like a whole nother like
okay exactly I want to make it easy for
you so where do I go to you is that the
video and then she like you I'm coming
to your city you just got them you just
gotta leave and I'ma follow it was lit
I'm like what the [__] that was the best
how was the video [__] I mean I mean
would you guys have fun or was it was it
we had we had a ball we had fun like
we've had past fun when you guys first
met was it obviously you talked on the
phone when you guys first meet it's like
Cardi's also one of those people who's
exactly who you think she is yeah she's
incredible she she exactly who she was
on that phone yeah so um we was I was
actually getting ready and I think she
was out doing her sing you know man and
it was like come on Fendi you gotta go
do a single party and this was my first
time you know we didn't even meet like
you know we ain't even go to the back or
none of that we just they was just like
go ahead get in the scene and it was
like a throw in the scene and I hopped
in and she was like oh my God you so
pretty and we hugged and it just went
from there that's amazing yes like
he's just sleep have you like because
you always I feel like when you have
a quick
trajectory like the last month of your
life has been
yeah there has to be some like do have
you seen the hate coming from like
because usually you get the most hate
from your hometown right yeah yeah yeah
yeah has there been like like any of
that that you have to deal with in terms
of like
maybe people acting different or acting
a little jealous or yeah like even at
the video shoot
it was just like love
hate but it got real like afterwards
after the video dropped
the hay got real but it's like I'm used
to it right
for sure it got real would you like uh
because I feel like a lot of people
who are from Chicago eventually end up
maybe getting a place somewhere else
still going home maybe keep a crib you
know a home base now that you're getting
bigger are you considering pivoting out
of you know because you know like at the
end of the day like like I said some of
the greatest artists we've had ever have
lost their life in their Hometown think
about golf Nipsey oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
um I'm definitely thinking about
um moving
I ain't trying to lose my life and
nobody else Hometown but I'm definitely
thinking about moving for sure
um for you I saw I just saw you did a
pride event you're a lesbian right yeah
yeah yeah
um for you like is it do do you like
because I think of like we've had so
many artists in hip-hop who were
like lesbian artists like I think a
young M.A you think of Queen Latifah for
you do you feel like uh any sort of like
burden to represent that community on a
bigger scale or are you just gonna do
you and if you know you're Unapologetic
for yourself but yeah that's one thing
about me like I'm just I just do me like
I'm just in my own lane doing my own
thing
um
I ain't trying to have none of that on
my back right I'm just I'm just me doing
me right right right
um whatever y'all see is what y'all you
know what that's what it is what y'all
get what y'all see what y'all see is
what y'all get gotta stop the interview
to say about our good Folks at Odd Socks
baby yeah shout out to odd talks now
this is what I love about Odd Socks one
their family we love them but also they
have the most comfortable socks in the
[__] world all right now look they
got the craziest licenses you see the
Jolly Rancher these are actually flies
[__]
some Dorito socks uh they got the WWE
license which is just my absolute
favorite and then um personally my
favorite is the odd Sox Basics now these
are just the basic socks so these are in
my bag because I'm taking these
I love these odd Sox basics
these are literally the most comfortable
socks in the world
all right these are just the plain guys
all right also they got the Scarface
they got the Godfather and they have
underwear
what are we talking about what are these
2XL Reese's Pieces you know if uh
somebody was gonna wear some Reese's
underwear I'd assume they'd be a 2x on
the size you know shots of the
Ghostbusters
um look so much going on at Odd Socks uh
what you got to do is go to
oddsoxofficial.com use that promo code
bootleg and you will save 20 off at
checkout all right it don't matter what
you're into they got all the licenses
Coca-Cola you could be a Pepsi guy
instead they got both you know what I'm
saying uh you're into maybe some anime
they got all the anime licenses they got
Naruto they also got um they just uh uh
rolled out the new uh Power Rangers
Transformers all that oddsoxofficial.com
use the promo code bootleg save 20 off
right now oh my goodness let me tell you
something the best part about my bookie
is not only is it the best sports book
period I mean look we're in the middle
of baseball season and baseball season
is Big Money season if you are a gambler
you know baseball is where you get the
Shmoney all right not only that but they
got the full-fledged casino going on all
right I'm telling you last night I'm on
my bookie I'm playing roulette with a
lady I'm looking at the lady she's on
video she's rolling the wheel it's a
movie all right they got Blackjack they
got uh whatever you're into Blackjack
craps oh man all kinds of slots some of
these slot games are so fun all right
listen everything you want all on one
site mybookie.ag this is the best part
when you sign up with our promo code
bootleg not only do you help us out but
you help yourself out because you're
gonna get that first deposit bonus money
to gamble with immediately free once you
sign up
mybookie.ag use the promo code bootleg
get the first deposit bonus right now
let's get back into the interview you
gotta get this bag they gotta book you
there's this I was in Miami I used to
live in Florida
and I went to South Beach one weekend
and I went to South Beach and it was
like the weekend of like stud Mayhem I
don't know what was going on right but
it was like the studs took over South
Beach really and it's like some event
they do every year but like everybody
look like Queen Latifah and said are you
serious or Little Wayne or younger man
you know what it is
no it wasn't Pride it was not Pride it's
something else it's like a stud thing so
it was like it was crazy it was crazy it
was like and I was talking I talked to
one of the home girls uh who I was we
were eating at a restaurant and I was
like yo what's going on there's some
event
um what's her name Jazzy who writes for
Diddy she's a Diddy's R B artist she she
knew the name of it I forget the name of
it but you got to get bagged yeah yeah
cause that [__] is crazy it's like all
the South Beach is just stuffed
yeah
I love to see that yeah no it's good
times for sure are you a big strip club
goer
um like I'm just a typo go with the flow
type of person
if we end up at a strip club okay well
you're gonna be ending up at a lot of
them I know and it's in the next like
year before the next like 30 days maybe
you never know I mean your record's
going [__] crazy so for sure
and um I have been to a couple they love
me yeah yeah so the best city obviously
Atlanta is amazing Atlanta
Houston
yeah them the two I got to go to Miami
yeah I went to Miami it was buzzing
Miami's wild yeah it was lit I got a
place called Tootsie's there oh yeah you
get the fried lobster tail oh and then
you get the lady to come and give you a
back massage are you serious yeah they
have what I said it's uh it's in Miami
it's called tootsies why ain't nobody
telling me about you Drake set up on his
song guy uh what did he say Tootsie's
getting shoulder rubs you don't even get
lap dances at tootsies you just there's
like a lady
who's like fully dressed with like a
little bottle of oil and she just like
there's like five of them just walking
around massaging are you serious yeah
it's amazing nah they need to take me to
sushi tonight you must have to take the
private jet over there great food
and we even strip clubs have the best
hot wings you gotta um reserve a what
you got a reserve to go there no you
just walk in [__] yeah yeah so what if
they have life
30 people walk in at 110 30 men and
there's five women in there
I mean that would be a I don't know what
time it'd probably be at like 7 30 in
the morning no 7 30 7 30 in the morning
is probably decent that'd probably be at
11 A.M if there was only five women
dancing it's a big place oh okay but
also you gotta go booby trap on the
river booby trap on the river is a movie
yeah
in the mix doing all that [__] uh-huh
what's been your biggest show so far
rolling loud
how was you did rolling a lot of Miami
right uh-huh what was because first of
all it's humid as [__] out there oh my
God Roman loud time it is swamp ass City
I could not believe that it is terrible
I mean I love rolling loud but this the
weather
yeah oh I ain't never felt nothing like
that yeah yeah I take that back
Vegas was so hot
yes
Vegas gets hot but it's a dry heat
yeah but Miami yeah Miami was hot I was
sweating so yeah Miami you'll have like
uh just sweat coming out of every
orifice system it's bad if you ain't got
that AC jamming yeah and then you gotta
walk even like bro that's the problem
it's [__] crazy
uh-huh and then you catch pneumonia yeah
exactly like I just walked from outside
I'm wet and now it's 60 degrees now I'm
sick thank you Miami thank you yeah on
top of that I may have had too many
shoulder rubs
how was that what was that like though
for you like touching that road on
outstage that's obviously a big bucket
list yes it was lit again like I was so
happy
and man I didn't went out there
I feel like I was in Chicago yeah it was
so lit I had a ball
it was like different from other love
other love stuff you know you get the
little bad the back end and then you're
right but the wrong allows a big the big
that was too different I'm like what all
type different kind of people you know
lit singing yo lyrics I'm like oh [__]
you meet anybody at Roman loud like any
other artists
um I definitely ran into eye candy
she got that uh keep that
song yeah it's going crazy
you can keep that [__] I can't say that
obviously but yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah I think it's the Trick Daddy sample
right oh it is yeah I think it's to take
it to the house
beat are you gonna um are you gonna
sample some old [__] because I feel like
right now
every artist is just remaking old
records
respectfully it's it's really a thing I
feel like I just saw Emily Chapa just
did the Nelly song
keep that eye candy is obviously an
older who song who'll say who sing that
song when they say
you don't love me
Gucci
Gucci you don't love me oh um yeah yeah
I just really did that you did that I
just did that I didn't do that Gucci you
don't love me same beat I didn't do the
beat no I just did
you don't love me it's kind of the thing
right now it's kind of like going back
and paying homage to the literally which
is what
Puff Daddy was doing in the 90s a lot
um for you uh talk to me about what you
would be doing
in a world in which you weren't making
music what was your other passion that
you would have pursued
um
I actually wanted to be a teacher
growing up me too I really wanted to be
a teacher I don't even know why I don't
have no patience for kids but I really
wanted to do that I wanted to be a
history teacher in high school I wanted
to be a reading teacher writing teacher
all that yeah and I wanted to do it for
like fifth and sixth graders I found out
how much teachers made it and then I was
like yeah yeah they always rubbed it in
my face but I still was a little excited
then but then I got older I'm like yeah
I mean the thing is is that's why
teachers are the best people because
they knowingly go to school and put
themselves in debt to make 55 000 a year
yeah so yeah they're Saints Among Us
yeah yeah so you would have been a
teacher yeah yeah then and then after
that I got into
um
security I was um unarmed security then
I went to armed security you were
security guard yeah you're very small
yeah yeah so you were strapped like
protect what were you protecting
like what were you securing was it a
place was it a business it was a
building an old folks home oh nice
that's got to be the easiest job that
was the easiest job ever what uh you get
the airpods in the ears all day yeah
look at that camera who are you here to
see exactly
and she died
you can't come in she got covered you
got to get the [__] out of here
it was that easy and simple every day
you're just sitting at a desk you gotta
sign in yes
sign in yeah go ahead she's down there
somewhere
I swear to God yes I know my grandma's
an old folks home yeah his dances you
gotta go sign in and then just oh yeah
just down there yeah yeah cafeteria
Buster right yeah
you'll find it
you'll find someone else to ask exactly
they is they is in there yes they in
there with the wheelchairs the rolling
chairs electronic chairs they that you
know what's crazy is like going into an
old folks home
smell yes it just smells like
[__] man
it smells like someone's getting their
diaper changed bruh like six feet away
everywhere it smells that and then it
also smells like
damn
someone's finna die
you know like how many times did they
did people pass away like I'm sure that
happened a lot right oh my God I just
got to share this one store and
it's it's over with but
this man
came into the property okay it was like
I want to say
I'm not gonna say uh old folks home it
was like a Rehabilitation
senior citizen building yeah oh okay old
folks oh folks home but it was like some
people in there like 50 like they could
walk talk do everything right this is
just where they're at they're like yeah
okay yeah they was literally good people
nice people wives of course dress nice
did you say white wife oh I think wife
or a husband he said they were white no
no no no no no no no no no wife husband
and they was like really regular people
so
um
this one man he was always just like
weird he came in every day in
one day he was leaving out with his
suitcase in the suitcase the man the man
couldn't even
carry the suitcase and he was just
dragging it dragging it
do you know this man
why we have a body in a suitcase yeah
Bonnie a body whose body and then listen
I wasn't even on the shift that night I
was on I came back that morning and it
happened for my um 1208 shift I was on
eight to four
I said when I ran the cameras back
because the man who was on this the
person who was on the shift wasn't even
paying attention they was all in a phone
so when I got there to the job right
exactly I got there at the four I heard
what was going on I say wait let me run
the cameras back I ran the cameras back
all the way back
this man was did he kill someone
tweaking yeah that yeah he killed
somebody yeah he just tweet like did you
find the cameras of when he killed
someone he did inside his apartment came
out with a big old suitcase right with a
dead body in it with it in there who do
you know who he killed I know exactly
who he did was it another old lady yeah
it was another old lady so maybe they
had like a Viagra rage like maybe she
died from like
you know yeah she's a heart attack or
yeah and he was like I gotta get rid of
this [__] you know and also like No
One's Gonna Miss Her Like She's here you
know exactly that's probably how he was
thinking about you don't think like that
with others so how did they find out
there was a body in the suitcase did
someone stop him and say sir what's up
what's up with the suitcaser
that's what I'm saying we know the
security guard didn't stop him he just
let him walk out and he just walked out
to the back of the building did he throw
the suitcase in the trash he just threw
the suitcase in the trash Oh my God like
what are you serious he took I watched
him he took all the garbage out the
trash and then he put it in and then he
took the
garbage she took out the trash and put
it back in the has to be a white guy
no oh really exactly
you know if I'm thinking of who's gonna
put a suitcase in a body I'm thinking
quite for sure you feel me and I'm
thinking like you tweaking
but yeah that was serious that was
somebody life that was someone family so
did some yeah no it's [__] up Rest In
Peace So did someone find the body and
that's how they or was someone just
missing someone was just missing
literally
it's [__] crazy and and you know how
they come get the garbage and you
weren't working that shift you would
have caught him oh yeah and I had to run
them cameras back but I definitely would
have caught him so when you're an armed
security guard is it a gun what are you
armed with or is it no no no you armed
with a gun unarmed not a gun arm with a
gun so when you have the do you have to
go through training yes you have to go
through training so you know your way
around a piece yeah
I wouldn't know what to do with a gun
I'd be like
I we not the same we're not
shout out to uh
my man Cyrus he knows what to do with
the gun hey let's stop the interview
real quick to tell you about our good
Folks at King Palm that's right man
shout out to King Palm uh we're talking
about nothing but that organic all right
that natural
Them Leafs all right there's no tobacco
involved and they're so smooth when you
smoke in them I love King Palms the only
thing I'm smoking out of now if you go
to your local uh liquor store you go to
your local smoke shop you can get King
Palms of course 7-Eleven's got the king
pongs and they have so many crazy
flavors like shout out to Sugar Shawn
who's from um Phoenix Arizona my
hometown he's got his own flavor they
just sent us these now what's dope about
King Palm is that they have the the
terpene infused flavors so at the end of
the tip of these pre-rolls right you get
the Leaf
you squeeze the tip that's what she said
and then you just get a burst of flavor
this is that honey mango all right now
this is the most important part this is
absolutely natural
tobacco-free leaves the cleanest way to
smoke all right trust me when I say it
man we love King Palm over here so many
flavors I mean shout out to the grape
shots of the honey mango shout out to
the sugar punch right here you know what
I'm saying look if you go to kingpom.com
right now you can get hooked up with
everything you need at 50 off if you use
the promo code bootleg
or bootleg Kev try either one of those I
forget which one it is it's bootleg or
it's bootleg Kev you know what the
correct promo code will be down below
use the one that's down here kingpom.com
get 50 off right now shout out to King
pong
also want to shout out to our good Folks
at Blue chew baby shout out to Bluetooth
now this was going on with Bluetooth man
everybody keeps asking me this Bluetooth
work yes it works but don't take my word
for it you're gonna get a month for free
when you go to bluetooth.com and you use
the promo code bootleg a month for free
now what is Bluetooth fellas if you're
dealing with erectile dysfunction fellas
if your dick is not getting as hard as
you'd like it to maybe for your wife oh
I don't know listen all you got to do is
go to bluetooth.com it has the same
active ingredients as Viagra and Cialis
but it's getting delivered to you in a
chewable form right to your door in
discreet packaging and you do not have
to go into a doctor's office to get
Bluetooth you go to bluetooth.com you
use the promo code bootleg you get a
month supply delivered to your door
discreetly of course
discreetly
no doctor's appointments no going and
leaving your house and sitting in a
Lobby and waiting for some you know lady
to call you in so you could tell her how
your cock's not working properly it
happens fellas all right bluetooth.com
take my word for it also take their word
for it because they're gonna give you a
month's supply for free just five dollar
shipping bluetooth.com promo code
bootleg uh let's get back to the
interview
um okay so are you working on like
what's what's coming because I'm sure
you're working on an album yeah how do
you work mixtape what's coming next I'm
working on the album
um I'm gonna probably throw a couple of
features on it
actually really I'm thirsty to work with
Asian now right now you're thirsty to
work with her or work with her work with
yeah I'm sure she'd be with it yeah yeah
yeah so uh does she know you wanna yeah
yeah yeah work whatever yeah like yeah
yeah
all right
for sure does she know you want to pull
the strap on her no not that I don't
understand I don't want to worry about
it like that well I don't know I mean
maybe you show her how to how to use a
gun yeah you know I'm pretty sure she
know how to do that I mean she was
dating King Vaughn I would hope so right
exactly if you're gonna date King vong I
rest your soul I hope you come out of
the relationship on the other side
knowing how to handle yourself you know
for sure rest in peace King Von so uh
Asian doll
yeah yeah but yeah I'm working on the
album mama let the um Fendi and karate
rat out for a couple of moments you got
two weeks
um and then I'm working on my um
a nice little raw album for y'all
how many songs in
12 12. I like that okay
so yeah
hopefully you get Asian doll cooking
that up
Asian doll not Asian
for sure shout out to her you know I'm
glad that uh
the doll thing kind of there was a lot
of dolls yeah yeah you remember that
that cash dog Cuban doll Asian doll yeah
yeah yeah oh yeah I like cash down cash
dog's incredible she's amazing and she's
beautiful she just had a kid shout out
to her congratulations Cuban doll was uh
she was she had like uh she got canceled
she was one of the first canceled people
are you serious I don't know Cuban Dale
she had a like a chick in a cage oh I
don't know nothing yeah it was crazy it
was crazy she was from I think she was
from Texas there was and then Cuban doll
and Asian doll had a beef because it was
like who's the doll right oh I don't
know really
yeah yeah anyway well look I obviously
uh the song's going crazy
congratulations thank you thank you
um of course uh you got more music on
the way project on the way I'm sure you
got some live shows coming yep yep
um anything else on the way you want to
talk about
uh you got to promote anything else you
got some like weed coming out or you got
like a
we gonna get into that next time okay
you'll get it tonight there it is
everybody
Fendi the rapper for sure
she is her own bodyguard
she is her own armed security
there it is podcast
hey this interview is brought to you by
our good Folks at hardean all right
shout out to the Jardine family in Las
Vegas makes you follow them Harding
underscore Las Vegas the number one
dispensary period all right the craziest
selection of previous premium cannabis
you can ask for plus when you go to
Hardy in Las vegas.com you can check out
all the other cool stuff they got going
on you know they got a whole weed
University happening in Vegas hardine is
where it's at all right so if you're in
Las Vegas you get into that taxi cab you
say take me to Jardin and when you get
there you tell the wonderful Bud tenders
that I sent you and they're going to
take care of you Harding underscore Las
Vegas go follow him and uh yeah we got
another interview coming soon